pipeau
suite lire soir sur deux réseaux de
télévision baidhani 30 parce qu'après le
deuxième débat présidentiel et les deux
camps dans la maison blanche donc ont
participé à ces grands forums
en même temps sur les deux réseaux
américains mais c'était peut-être
l'occasion peu américain de mieux
comprendre les idées les visions des
états unis de dubaï des doigts dans
l'europe parce qu'au premier débat
c'était plutôt raté mais que doit-on
retenir c'est notre karma mécanique car
une pré mon professeur agrégé de
politiques adverses et chez bourbon soir
karine léger le pari correspondant pour
le monde à voir je t'aime j'oserais dire
ami de l'émission je suis partie bonsoir
on a stratège américain qui a dit que
pour monsieur badini te pique nique et
que pour monsieur chrome c'était un
interrogatoire
est ce qu'on peut se demander karine si
monsieur trump aurait préféré un débat
que cette interview mon coeur que
j'adore ça le dise qu'on appelle
familièrement des autres sites
elle n'y a pas eu une elle s'attrape été
facile pour lui disant ça n'a pas été
facile mais je pense qu'il a misé sur ce
format là plutôt qu'elle débarrasse 4
des vols commis des bords appellent les
journaux les analystes des gens on se
dirait qu'il n'avait pas bien fait son
style avait énervé beaucoup de gens même
des républicains qui voulaient voter
pour lui
je pense que c'était dhiba et je reste
pas grand-chose à faire un autre a
essayé une autre format je pense qu'il
pensait avoir plus de contrôle peut-être
à ce moment là et il avait l'espace à
lui tout seul et l'impact du coût
partagé les estrades donc je pense qu'il
avait misé là dessus
évidemment avec madame de tuer la
journaliste elle n'a pas laissé passer
beaucoup ont peut-être que s'attendait
pas à autant de de combativité cépage
est fier il sait qu méfiance comme est
ici pour préparer non plus comme il le
fait généralement pas de toute façon
pour ce genre de trucs votre analyse
vous il paris oui effectivement
donald trump a repris la campagne avec
une énergie qui est toujours aussi
impressionnante et il était et est
hospitalisé il était malade et malgré
tout ça il continue à battre la campagne
à parcourir les états mais c'est un peu
l'homme prisonnier d'un seul discours
son discours de campagne qui la scène
avec ses blagues avec ces moments
d'emportement et ça marche devant les
supporters mais ça marche pas face à un
public
et ça marche pas face à une journaliste
là on peut noter que joe biden de son
côté a été - harcelée par l'animateur de
la chaîne nbc c'était beaucoup plus
confortable il ya peut-être une petite
inégalités de ce point de vue qui était
pointé d'ailleurs par la campagne de
donald trump
mais le fait est que ce deux séances en
montrer qu'il y avait d'un côté l'ancien
vice-président qui savent exactement ce
qu'ils voulaient dire il voulait aller
et c'est un format qui lui convenait
parle avec les gens ils aiment pas et ça
se voit et de l'autre un président en
fonction qui se débattent dans que par
tous les moyens de relancer sa campagne
et pour l'instant ça ne marche pas ça
marchera pas parce qu'au fond ce qu'on
apprend aujourd'hui c'est que ben laden
avait plus de cotes d'écouté sur le
réseau nbc
4'
et puis quel bon le taux de vote par
anticipation est très élevée on apprend
différentes choses que je m'endors
honneur que son ancien chef de cabinet
le général kelly a dit que c'était la
personne la plus la plupart fait qu'il
ait connu ou qu'ils connaissent
chris christie dit le l'a5 bonheur du
dojo dit j'aurais dû portant un masque à
la maison blanche ça se défait karine
autour de trompes au fur et à mesure
qu'on approche de la date de l'élection
évidemment il ya certains républicains
qui vont commencer à mesurer leurs
chances de réélection aussi le et se
dire baisse que j'ai plus de chance avec
trust pousse en chambre parce que il
nuit à ma campagne et on vise devoir
peut-être quelques défections et des
gens qui ont déjà commencé à ne pas
prononcer son nom pendant sa campagne
par exemple voient refuser que qui est
une association directe avec change mais
en même temps depuis le début et et
monsieur paris tout à fait raison depuis
le début de choses ne parle qu'à sa base
et capacité à aller chercher d'autres
personnes alors évidemment mais il faut
surtout avec à peu près 10 points
l'écart dans les sondages nationaux avec
diaw 10 points d'écart en effet son
ingestion d'eau dans les états pivots g
paris comment la situation évolue tel
pour se tromper
ici sa campagne ne démarre pas qu'est ce
qu'il doit faire rapidement pour
regagner des points
c'est toute la question salaire qu'au
niveau des états les carrés et moins
moins large
- grand il encore en situation de
pouvoir renverser la vapeur
je souvenir que il ya quatre ans à la mi
octobre
hillary clinton était largement en tête
et puis une dynamique s'était enclenchée
en sa défaveur travers pouvoir
l'enclencher de son côté mais on voit
pas encore quelques éléments pourraient
y concourir
hillary clinton on s'en souvient avait
été victime entre guillemets de l'
ouverture une enquête du fbi ya et qui
portait sur des vieux email savait
qu'elle avait d'autant plus pénalisé que
son image était négative joe biden lui
il a une image positive quand on voit la
différence entre les avis défavorables
est favorable ils sont positifs
quand on regarde s'il est considéré
comme honnête bas par rapport à 2003 il
est considéré comme beaucoup plus
honnête
donc il n'ya pas de paiement de failles
sur laquelle sur lesquels
de la drum pourrait appuyer on le voit
avec 70 hâtive malheureuse de relancer
les critiques sur le comportement du
fils de joe biden under way et sur la
suppression des votes où le risque de
voir des votes être voler littéralement
karine sur le développement démocratique
de cette élection là est ce que trame
continuer à nourrir la peur ou pas c'est
sûr parce que ça fait longtemps qu'il le
fait c'est peut-être la seule chance de
pouvoir contester une défaire donc à
partir de ce moment là de dire aux
électeurs d'écouté il ya tellement de
vote qui sont jetés aux ordures en
particulier les votes sont faits pour
jobs alors que pas de façon de savoir de
son côté jeudi asseoir encore lequel il
est dit à millas le voir mais sur wii
donc et ça c'est pas prouvé bien sûr
qu'on continue à faire fort on continue
à déligitimer le vote par la force de
votre participation au kazoo et c'est
pour ça aussi qu'il souhaite avoir un
troisième juge locaux d'où on devrait
rebaisser scénario infernal de deux
villes on va y venir tout de suite un
mba ou dans un instant mais justement
les mensonges de monsieur propre hier
soir gilles paris si j'étais quand même
assez nombreux ce soit sur la colline
sur la gestion de la coved
aujourd'hui nous avons frôlé les 2 sens
entre 1 219 nullement le 8 millions
d'américains il dit qu'un traitement il
dit que les gens qui portent le masque
attrape la côte vide bon et c'est
justement alors que cuba ne me connaît
pas mais bien deux - dicton les kills si
j'enlève les mecs qui était bien
contente ça est ce que tous ces
mensonges là vont finir sans lui nuire
ou pas je suis problème c'est qu'ils
créent une bulle c'est sa conseillère
qu'il ya une conway qui avait inventé la
formule de fai alternatifs moins ému du
mandat c'est une façon de biaiser de ne
pas avoir à répondre justement de de
fait précis mais en fait ça se
transforme en piège parce que donald
trump tournent en boucle sur ces
affirmations
encore une fois ils les répètent
tellement lors des meetings que ça
devient un langage naturel pour lui
or il n'est pas du tout crédible sur la
question du coronavirus il n'est pas
crédible sur beaucoup de sujets et donc
il se il se pénalise lui-même en en
étant prisonnier de cette et propres
mots et ses propres de l'exagération
alors là madame barbe est la candidate
juge à la cour suprême
les démocrates sont devant des faits
accomplis karine ça va se faire ça va se
confirmer
qui ça va profiter la question à qui ça
va profiter parce que je pense que si
les démocrates ne le font pas trop de
positions au moins ça ne va pas leur
venue et c'est sûr que ça va
éventuellement profiter aux républicains
parce que si les procédures peuvent
aller aussi rapidement qu'ils
républicains voudraient la nouvelle juge
pourrait siéger dès le 2 novembre et le
2 novembre
on entend une première cause importante
sur les droits de la communauté lgbt qu
versus et liberté religieuse est aussi
sur la fameuse loi obamacare est donc ce
sont des chevaux de bataille très
important pour les républicains donc qui
pourrait éventuellement tirer profit de
cette nomination rapide et là tu
monsieur bart hayden je le paierai pas
voulu se prononcer vraiment clairement
hier s'il allait augmenter le nombre de
jeux
pour reprendre l'expression très
québécoise pour paqueter la couronne à
des ces parkings en une expression très
québécois ce pacte est la cour en
augmentant le nombre de juges une patate
chaude pour monsieur bart hayden à 18
jours des élections alors ce que ce
qu'est ce qui est impressionnant c'est
l'incapacité de la part du camp
démocrate a formulé avancé des éléments
de langage un peu consistants est vrai
que joe biden sur ce point est assez
fluctuant assez flou tant on l'a dit
hier qu'ils allaient se prononcer après
la nomination et éventuellement de la
juge conservatrice on c'est pas trés pas
très convaincant le fait est que je ne
sais pas vraiment un sujet de
préoccupation pour les américains
lorsqu'on regarde les sondages c'est
toujours l'économie le corona virus donc
il n'est pas très pas très convaincant
pas très bon sur ce sujet mais je pense
pas que ça le pénalise énormément
alors là dessus je vous dit bonsoir on
va se préparer pour le débat de la
semaine prochaine ça va certainement
être important à suivre le dernier avant
donc cette élection du 3 novembre
kirin vraiment merci beaucoup je parlais
aussi merci beaucoup et très dont votre
canapé